hi und herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir blicken heute erneut auf den Krieg
in der Ukraine Russland setzt seine
Angriffe fort da werden Wohnhäuser
zerstört wie hier ihr seht die Bilder
aus Croissant der Stadt die ja ohnehin
schon schwer von den Überschwemmungen
infolge der Zerstörung des kartofka
Staudamms getroffen wurde und
gleichzeitig also neben diesen Angriffen
setzt die Ukraine ihre Gegend Offensive
fort diese Bilder sollen zeigen wie
ukrainische Soldaten nahe der lange
umkämpften Stadt bachmut vorrücken
insgesamt habe man bei bereits 7
Siedlungen zurückerobert so heißt es aus
Kiel ja und wir wollen hier heute bei
ZDF heute live darüber sprechen braucht
es noch mehr Waffenlieferung wie geht es
eigentlich den Menschen vor Ort an der
Front und kurz hinter der Front und
schafft die Ukraine den Durchbruch und
das diskutiere ich immer nicht alleine
sondern mit Gästen zum einen mit
Militärexperte Markus Kolb von der
Militärakademie der et Zürich dann mit
zdf-reporterin Alissa jung in der Nähe
von saporisha und mit ZDF nato-kurs von
Land Florian neuhahn in Brüssel wenn ihr
Fragen an diese Gäste habt oder einfach
mal eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns
teilen wollt dann tut das wie immer sehr
sehr gerne wir brauchen für diese
Sendung eure Kommentare und eure Fragen
tut das gerne im Youtube Chat oder
schreibt eine Mail an die Mailadresse
die ihr gerade im Bild eingeblendet seht
und bevor wir jetzt richtig loslegen mit
unserer Sendung und unserer Diskussion
stellen wir euch noch mal den
Militärexperten Markus Käufer
militär-experte mit scharfen Blick auf
den russischen Angriffskrieg Markus Kolb
arbeitet seit 2013 als Dozent für
militärökonomie an der Militärakademie
der ETH Zürich der Ausbildungsstätte für
die Berufsoffiziere der Schweizer Armee
in seiner Forschung beschäftigt er sich
vor allem damit wie sich militärische
Organisationen effizient und effektiv
aufstellen können als Einschätzung zum
Angriffskrieg sind gefragt für print
online und im TV seine These Russland
wird den Krieg im Oktober militärisch
verloren haben
ja und hier ist er mir jetzt schon live
zugeschaltet hallo Herr Kolb schön dass
sie mal wieder bei uns sind hallo guten
Abend grüße sie wir haben ja schon ganz
oft in den letzten Wochen in den letzten
Monaten über die Offensive gesprochen
und da haben wir uns vor allem gefragt
läuft sie schon wann kommt sie wo wird
sie kommen und jetzt können wir mit
Sicherheit sagen die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive läuft Herr Kolb was ist
denn ihre erste Einschätzung wie läuft
diese Offensive für die Ukraine
also ich denke wir sind im nächsten
Stadium der Offensive das heißt also die
Ukraine versucht im Moment einfach an
verschiedenen Punkten vorzustoßen und
quasi die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen an zu testen
also wo kommt man am leichtesten durch
bzw wo ist der Widerstand am geringsten
und ich muss immer wieder warnen wenn
das Publikum so erwartet es kommt ein
großer romantischer Durchbruch auf einer
breiten Front so nach dem Motto gegen
Zweiten Weltkrieg ähm das wird nicht
passieren sondern wir werden für längere
Zeit jetzt die diese kleinen dezentralen
vorschlüsse sehen nicht nur weil es so
der ukrainischen Offensive passt sondern
auch weil die der Ukraine ein sehr viel
deutlicheres Bild geben wie es jetzt
wirklich bestellt ist um diese
russischen Gräben also sprich sind die
wirklich bemannt und befestigt und
schwer verteidigt oder stehen sie
einfach nur in der Landschaft und dann
kann sie relativ schnell überrollen und
die Ukraine führt natürlich nicht nur
diese eigentlichen Aktion durch sondern
sie testet auch an anderen Stellen der
Front und sie lenkt auch die an anderen
Stellen ab deswegen sehen wir zum
Beispiel wie sie vorhin gezeigt haben
diese Bilder aus bachmut es gibt nach
wie vor diese trolloperationen im Raum
Belgorod es gibt seit heute einen neuen
Vorstoß in Richtung marienka und auch
ein in Richtung
und das ganze zwingt natürlich die
Russen zu schwierigen Entscheidungen
weil sie jetzt nicht wissen ist das
jetzt die Offensive ist dass der
Durchbruch oder ist das nur ein Test
sollen wir jetzt Ressourcen dahin
verlagern oder nicht und die Ukraine die
im Moment die Initiative hat kann sich
aussuchen wo sie diese Aktion durchführt
ja und zum genauen Frontverlauf zur
offensiven Strategie und auch zu den
Herausforderungen für die Ukrainer
sprechen wir gleich noch mal Herr Kolb
jetzt schalten wir aber erst noch mal zu
meiner Kollegin Alissa jung in die
Ukraine sie ist in saporisha hat aber
vor kurzem die Möglichkeit eben nicht in
saporisha sondern in einem ganz kleinen
Ort 20 km vor der Front hier sehen wir
ihn mit Ukrainern und Ukrainerinnen zu
sprechen und darüber sprechen wir jetzt
mit ihr hallo Alissa schön dass du bei
uns bist
hallo Viktoria wir haben gerade auf der
Karte gesehen du warst an diesem Ort der
wirklich nur 20 km vor der Frontlinie
ist was hast du dort erlebt
wir waren in komisch kommen für mich ist
schwer auszusprechender Ort und dem
waren wir was das gesagt rund 20 km noch
bis zur Frontlinie sind es haben dort
sowohl mit dem Bürgermeister als auch
eben mit AnwohnerInnen und Händlerinnen
dort vor Ort gesprochen es ist ein
kleiner Ort mit einer Straße der die
dort durchführt wo auch
Militärtransporte durchfahren bis runter
zur Frontlinie eben dieser Ort war in
der Vergangenheit immer wieder unter
starkem heftigen Beschuss jetzt hat mir
der Bürgermeister bestätigt ist es ein
bisschen weniger geworden weil sich eben
die Frontlinie ein bisschen verlagert
hat das heißt für diesen Ort jetzt
zumindest für den Moment mal ganz kurz
durchatmen was wir dort erlebt haben
sind aber viele zerstörte Gebäude man
hat einfach ganz klar gesehen dass
dieser Ort sehr lange sehr heftig auch
immer wieder Einschläge hatte haben das
auch bestätigt bekommen von den
AnwohnerInnen die uns das berichtet
haben und das ist für die Menschen dort
natürlich eine schreckliche Situation
und gleichzeitig aber auch eine
schreckliche Normalität geworden und da
erzählt uns der Bürgermeister das ist
natürlich auch etwas Gefährliches denn
jetzt auch zum Beispiel hier aktuell
vielleicht hört jetzt gerade wir haben
hier ein saporisha auch gerade wieder
raketenalarm und wenn eben dort in
diesem Ort der noch näher ist zur Front
also nicht nur in Alarm zu hören ist
vielleicht auf dem Smartphone auch man
hat das ganze ja auch auf einer App wenn
so ein Alarm ausgelöst wird sondern wenn
sogar Beschuss zu hören ist gehen
einfach viele Menschen dort überhaupt
nicht mehr in einen Bunker in einen
Keller suchen keinen Schutz mehr denn
Sie haben sich an diesen schrecklichen
Beschuss auch schon gewöhnt und da sagte
der Bürgermeister uns dass das natürlich
eine gefährliche Normalität ist wenn man
keine Schutz sucht ganz klar ist man
auch viel wohl eine Radler um dann
verletzt zu werden insofern hat dieser
Ort schon wirklich sehr viel erlebt und
dementsprechend haben sich die Menschen
dort natürlich auch schon angepasst an
diese Situation
ja und wir sehen auch du hast dich an
die Situation schon angepasst wir hören
da sie reden du berichtest aber weiter
wir müssen wir uns das denn vorstellen
wie gewöhnt man sich an so etwas also
mit welchen Parametern ist jetzt z.B du
oder messen die Menschen die da leben ob
sie in einen Schutzbunker gehen oder
nicht
raketenalarm wird immer großflächig für
eine Region ausgelöst das heißt man hört
den dann also wirklich in der gesamten
Region und das ist sehr sehr häufig am
Tag ich kann gar nicht tatsächlich
wirklich gar nicht mitzählen wie oft das
heute war 3 4 5 mal denn wenn wir jetzt
jedes Mal in einen Bunker gehen würden
wenn raketenalarm ist dann würden wir
nur noch da sitzen und für die Menschen
die hier leben ist das ja noch viel mehr
Alltag und Realität die erleben das seit
anderthalb Jahren und für die würde das
auch bedeuten dass sie ausschließlich im
Bunker sitzen jetzt sind wir hier in
saporisa ja natürlich auch von der
Frontlinie entfernt deswegen sage ich
mal können wir das hier vielleicht auch
uns natürlich leisten jetzt keine Schutz
zu suchen je näher man natürlich an die
Frontlinie kommt desto gefährlicher die
Situation aber auch da ich habe es eben
berichtet hat sich da eben auch schon
eine gewisse ein Leben ein Leben mit
diesen Kriegsalltag eingestellt das ist
für die Menschen hier ja einfach bittere
Realität seit fast anderthalb Jahren
der Ort in dem du warst was für Menschen
leben da aktuell
tatsächlich leben da auch noch 700
Kinder in der Region hat uns der
Bürgermeister erzählt die sind aber in
der Regel zu Hause bei ihren Eltern denn
es ist auch so das kleine Kinder auch
gar nicht unten die Begleitung der
Eltern raus dürfen wir haben allerdings
Teenager getroffen auf der Straße auch
die Leben jetzt selbst gar nicht mehr in
dem Ort also da gibt es auch
Unterschiede manche sind geblieben
manche sind eben nicht mehr dort sondern
die Leben eigentlich hier in saporisha
das waren zwei Mädchen 16 und 18 Jahre
alt die haben aber die Großmutter der
einen eben dort besucht ihr beim
Einkaufen geholfen also zum Besuch sind
sie mal dahin gefahren sie haben uns
berichtet dann doch dass sie sich gar
nicht an diesen Krieg natürlich gewöhnen
wollen dass sie damit leben aber das ist
schon einfach ihr ganzes Leben verändert
hat das von einem normalen Teenager da
sein nicht mehr zu sprechen ist sie
kommen in ihren Freunden kommen noch
zusammen sind ja auch gar nicht mehr
alle an einem Ort lange hat die Schule
hat die Universität ja auch nur virtuell
stattgefunden es gibt einfach auch gar
nicht mehr Möglichkeiten für sie
wirklich zusammen zu kommen zusammen zu
sein ein Sorg loses Leben zu leben und
wir haben gespürt in der Unterhaltung
aber auch in der ja in der ganzen
natürlich Art wie die Mädchen uns das
erzählt haben die jungen Frauen dass das
auch etwas ist was sie natürlich sehr
traurig macht sehr belastet denn sie
haben einfach damit jetzt ihre
Teenagerjahre zunächst mal aufgegeben
und wissen ja auch gar nicht wann sie
die wieder bekommen
ja und wie blicken denn diese Menschen
von denen Du berichtest also
Teenagerin Menschen die jetzt nicht an
vorderster Frauen kämpfen aber eben
relativ eng dahinter ihr normales Leben
irgendwie gestalten müssen wie blicken
die denn aktuell auf diese Offensive
sind die dazuversichtlich spürt man da
noch diesen ukrainischen Kampfgeist von
dem er jetzt in den letzten eineinhalb
Jahren immer wieder die Rede war
ja sie sind zuversichtlich sie wollen
auch an den sie glauben das sagt uns
jeder mit dem wir hier sprechen wirklich
ausnahmslos egal wo wir hinkommen ja man
glaubt an den Sieg natürlich niemand
weiß wie schnell das gehen könnte das
ist jetzt nicht worüber hier die
Menschen die normalen Menschen mit denen
wir auf der Straße sprechen irgendwie
Prognosen dazu abgeben wollen aber sie
glauben so fest an den Sieg dass der
Bürgermeister z.B auch schon über die
Zeit danach gesprochen hat er hat gesagt
er möchte vor allem in der Zeit danach
was für ihn besonders wichtig ist in
diesem zerstörten Ort denn man muss sich
das so vorstellen vor allem sind die
Fabriken dort kaputt die Infrastruktur
ist kaputt er hat uns auch noch mal sehr
deutlich gesagt dass Militär also die
russische Seite zieht eben nicht nur auf
Militär sondern einfach auch ganz klar
auf alles was Infrastruktur dort
bedeutet was wirtschaftlichen
wirtschaftliches Leben dort bedeutet und
das ist alles kaputt also für ihn ganz
wichtig dann in der Zeit wenn die
Ukraine dann dann gewonnen haben sollte
der Wiederaufbau und die Menschen die
ins Ausland geflohen sind auch wieder
zurückzuholen in seinen Ort er sagt er
hatte moderne er wollte sie wollten ein
Stadion bauen sie wollten etwas für
Kinder tun sie wollten diesen Ort
entwickeln und jetzt hat er uns erzählt
geht es einfach nur noch darum die
nötigste Versorgung sicherzustellen und
einfach tatsächlich zu überleben und das
ist natürlich dann doch wieder sehr weit
weg von irgendwas was wir nur annähernd
als Normalität bezeichnen würden
deswegen muss man das natürlich auch
einordnen dass das was hier dann
vielleicht als Normalität gelebt ist
natürlich keine Normalität sein darf
eigentlich
Alisa vielen vielen Dank für diese
wichtigen Einblicke von vor Ort und
alles Gute in die Ukraine
bevor wir jetzt noch mal mit Herrn Keup
sprechen möchten wir noch mal einen
Blick nach Brüssel werfen dort hat sich
nämlich heute Vormittag die sogenannte
Ukraine Kontaktgruppe getroffen ihr
kennt sie vielleicht auch unter dem
Rammstein Begriff dort trifft sie sich
auch um über Waffenlieferungen für die
Ukraine gegen Russland zu beraten und
über die Ergebnisse dieses Treffen
spreche ich jetzt mit unserem NATO
Korrespondent Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
der mir zugeschaltet das hallo Florian
was wurde denn was wurde denn bei diesem
Treffen der Ukraine Kontaktgruppe heute
Vormittag beschlossen hinsichtlich
weiterer militärischer Unterstützung für
die Ukraine
naja es wurde noch mal breit über alles
gesprochen was die Ukraine jetzt braucht
und es wurde natürlich auch über die
Meldung der letzten Tage gesprochen da
gab es ja das berühmte Bild das Russland
eben sehr stolz in allen Formen der
Propaganda präsentiert hat das
zerstörten wohl deutschen Leopard
Panzers und da gab es die konkrete
Ansage ziemlich deutlich von Seiten des
deutschen Ministers Boris Pistorius der
sagte nein es gibt dafür keinen Ersatz
ganz einfach deshalb weil Deutschland
keine weiteren Leopard 2 A6 Panzer mehr
hat die ist noch nie liefern könnte es
wird aber ab Juli 100 das war bereits
lange geplant 100 Leopard 185 Panzer
liefern also etwas ältere Bauart aber
immerhin davon auch sehr viele die von
der Industrie gerade noch fit gemacht
werden dann aber gab es auch weitere
Ankündigungen von militärische Hilfe die
wichtigste ist wohl die von vier Staaten
aus den USA Großbritannien den
Niederlanden und Dänemark die nämlich
sagen sie werden relativ kurzfristig der
Ukraine hunderte weitere
Flugabwehrraketen liefern für die kurze
und mittlere Reichweite genau das was
das Land jetzt braucht um sich eben
gegen diese Angriffe aus der Luft von
Drohnen und Raketen zu verteidigen
insofern kann die Ukraine hier mit etwas
mehr sozusagen an militärischer Hilfe
von diesem Treffen wieder abreisen ob es
dann ausreicht wird man sehen man ist
hier noch sehr verhalten in der
Kommentierung der bisherigen ersten
Versuche bei dieser Gegend Offensive
ja und neben dieser Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe haben sich ja dann heute
Nachmittag noch mal die
Nato-Verteidigungsminister
zusammengesetzt und ein Punkt der nicht
auf der Tagesordnung stand der aber in
den letzten Wochen immer wieder im Raum
steht weil sich auch
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
immer wieder dazu geäußert hat ist ja
der NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine was ist da
denn der aktuelle Stand der Verhandlung
oder der Gespräche
ich würde sagen es gibt jetzt zwei Lager
in der Allianz da sind die einen
angeführt von den Osteuropäern den
baltischen Staaten die ja auch eine ganz
konkrete Perspektive drängen und sagen
auf dem Gipfel in Vilnius in ich glaube
drei vier Wochen da wollen wir der
Ukraine einen konkreten Fahrplan
anbieten ganz konkret sagen ihr werdet
am besten sofort nach Ende des Krieges
aufgenommen und dann gibt es das andere
Lager mit dem diese aus Europäer auch
sehr unzufrieden sind dass er Lager eben
der Bremser mit vor allem zwei
prominenten Mitgliedern Deutschland und
dann auch den USA interessanterweise die
eben sagen wir wollen jetzt keine
konkrete Zusage machen es gibt jetzt
keine Möglichkeit irgendwas zu
versprechen weil wenn ich wissen wie
lange dieser Krieg dauern wird und da
ein zahlt man aufzustellen dass hielte
man halte man für wirklich wieder sinnig
für absurd man müsste jetzt über die
konkrete Hilfe reden
jetzt gibt es ich sag mal einen kleinen
Fortschritt an kleinen Kompromiss etwas
was man der Ukraine anbietet es gibt
nämlich bisher einen NATO
ukrainekommission die das hat man heute
beschlossen will man aufwerten zu einem
NATO Ukraine Rat das klingt jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen absurd aber in
der Tat es wäre hier ein kleiner
Fortschritt weil die Ukraine damit
erstmals gleichberechtigt mit allen
NATO-Alliierten mit am Tisch säße und
die Diplomaten mit denen wir sprechen
geben sich größte Mühe das in den
Hintergrundgesprächen als großen
Fortschritt zu verkaufen aber natürlich
wird das die Ukraine ziemlich sicher
enttäuschen diese kleine Aufwertung von
der Kommission nur zum Rad
ja wir hören also ein neuer Name das
bringt der Ukraine erstmal nicht so viel
und weitere Gespräche über militärische
Unterstützung vielen Dank Florian
ja und darüber wie notwendig solche
weiteren militärischen Lieferungen
Unterstützung sind für die Offensive und
welche Strategie die Ukraine mit dieser
Offensive aktuell verfolgt darüber
spreche ich jetzt noch mal mit
militär-experte Markus Kolb schön dass
sie wieder da sind hallo lassen Sie uns
mal direkt auf die Karte gucken mich und
sicher auf die Zuschauer und Zuschauerin
interessiert jetzt wo läuft die
ukrainische Offensive aktuell und welche
Strategie wird da an verschiedenen
Punkten verfolgt ja also es gibt im
Moment zwei
hauptstöße entlang der Front und zwar
dafür müssten sie mal kurz von der Stadt
saporicia hinein zoomen und zwar in
südöstlicher Richtung dann kommen Sie zu
einem kleinen Ordner namens Oliver
eben hatte ich ihn hier ist er hier ist
eure genau und jetzt sehen sie im
südlich von von euch hilft geht wenn Sie
genau südlich schauen dann geht das in
Richtung der Stadt tokmark und die Stadt
todmark ist sehr gut zu erkennen weil
die so einen Ring von von Gräben oder
von von russischen
befestigungsstrukturen um sich hat und
das ist die eine Zuschauer das muss ich
vielleicht einmal noch einschränken
genau die roten Punkte und diese roten
Linien die hier seht das sind russische
verteidigungswelle die hier
eingezeichnet sind genau
das ist im Moment die die eine
Stoßrichtung der ukrainischen Offensive
in diesen Sekt ist wichtig weil dort
eine Eisenbahnlinie vorbei führt über
die die russische Logistik ihre Südfront
versorgt und ähm sie sehen auch das
Problem dieser russischen
Verteidigungslinien also zunächst man
darf man sich das nicht so vorstellen
wie im ersten oder im zweiten weltkriegt
dass das also quasi ein komplexes
systematisch angelegtes Grabensystem ist
sondern sie sehen das ist stellenweise
löchrig das ist stellenweise einfach
improvisiert ja also wild im Gelände
angelegt und es gibt natürlich auch
Lücken zwischen diesen Gräben und die
die übergeordnete Aufgabe für die
Ukraine ist jetzt natürlich
herauszufinden wo kommt sie am
leichtesten durch aber auch wo sind die
lohnenden Zielen und sie sehen einen
dritten Punkt nämlich das hintertoc Mark
also wenn Sie jetzt auf der Karte noch
so ein bisschen weiter Scrollen in
Richtung Süden und dann bis sie an der
bis sie an der Schwarzmeerküste sind da
sehen sie da kommt nicht mehr viel und
ähm auch das gibt einen in eine Idee ähm
was die ukrainische Offensive für eine
Stoßkraft erreichen kann wenn sie mal
durch diese Linie durch ist also sprich
sobald sie durch sind hinter dieser
Linie steht nichts mehr aber dann kommt
die schwarz mehr Küste und dann sind
tatsächlich Bewegung denkbar dass die
Russen z.B gegen ihre eigenen Gräben
geworfen werden oder eben zurück an die
schwarzen Küste und dann nicht mehr weg
können und dann das ist jetzt ein sehr
entscheidender Moment und die Ukraine
versucht eben jetzt heraus finden wo in
diesem in diesem unübersichtlichen
stellenweise löcherigen System kommt sie
am besten durch und in dieser Vormarsch
von euch hilft in Richtung togmak der
läuft zwar aber er läuft im Moment
relativ zäh also große große
Geländegewinne sind da noch nicht zu
ersehen aber wenn wir jetzt auf den
südöstlichen Stoß gehen da läuft das
schon im Moment deutlich besser für die
Ukraine und zwar dafür müssten sie von
saporicia aus ziemlich exakt nach Osten
gehen aber dann kommt sie zu einer
Ortschaft namens welicona
mal schauen da müssen wir jetzt etwas
stärker hinein zoomen in ja in den Ort
werde ich dann aber sie kann und dann
sehen sie da geht eine Straße ab nach
Süden die t0518 die hier oder ja genau
und Sie sehen dass die Ukraine hier
anders als die Russen ist vielleicht
gedacht haben also nicht nicht breit
durch das geländevorschrift sondern sie
fahren im Prinzip auf dieser Straße von
Dorf zu Dorf und bewegen sich jetzt
einfach nach Süden durch und im Moment
stehen sie so zwischen Margarita und
darum also wenn sie von wenig Ahnung was
circa auszählen das ist jetzt das äh das
fünfte Dorf und ähm so nach nachdem
berichten die wir im Moment vor allem
für den Russen bekommen es finden die
Kämpfe gerade so im Raum statt und sie
sehen da da ist auch ein grundsätzliches
informations Problem weil wenn die
Ukraine verrückt dann hat sie sogenannte
operational Security das heißt also dann
gehen alle Handys aus dann gehen alle
berichtskanäle offline dann sagt niemand
mehr was und Sie wissen nicht wirklich
wo stehen Sie jetzt was machen Sie jetzt
und in der Phase ist das einzige was man
da noch anschauen kann die russischen
Telegramm Kanäle oder die russischen
militärblogger die muss man dann
natürlich aber sehr stark diskontieren
und und auch mit mit deutlich kritischen
Augen sehen aber so so bewegt sich das
Ganze quasi fort also wir beobachten im
Moment sagen die russischen
militärblogger irgendwas und dann nimmt
man das erstmal hin und dann wartet man
ob das zwei drei Tage später dann von
den Ukrainern bestätigt wird das heißt
also das was wir jetzt im Moment sehen
ähm aus dem Kampfgebiet das ist meistens
einige Tage alt sodass man nicht exakt
immer sagen kann wo stehen Sie jetzt
genau aber ich denke so in diesem Raum
Margarita bist oder seine da das ist im
Moment der ukrainische Vorschuss und sie
sehen jetzt wie das weitergeht also wenn
Sie der Straße 18 jetzt weiter folgen
und sie gehen jetzt noch zwei Dörfer
herunter dann kommen auch schon die
ersten roten Punkte also da beginnt die
russische hautverteidigungslinie und
wenn Sie jetzt vielleicht noch etwas
stärker hineinzonen also weil es darum
zum Beispiel das sehen Sie da ist also
noch nichts und jetzt gehen sie die
Straße bisschen weiter runter Richtung
oder
die ersten die ersten kleinen Punkte die
aber überwiegend im Gelände liegen
und jetzt ist eben die Frage kann die
Ukraine entlang dieser Straße weiter
vorstoßen dann könnte sie nämlich diese
Befestigungsanlagen umgehen oder sind
die so gestaltet dass die Russen quasi
seitlich auf die Straße von dort aus
schießen dann müssen Sie zunächst mal
diese Befestigung rausnehmen aber sie
sehen auch wie löcherig die Anlagen hier
sind also sind wirklich vereinzelte
vereinzelte Anlagen im Gelände die aber
nicht weiter verbunden sind und Sie
sehen dass sowas logistisch natürlich
auch schwierig zu unterhalten ist also
das ist kein durchgehender grabengang wo
sie quasi Logistik in ost-richtung hin
und herschieben können und wir wissen im
Moment nicht wirklich wie stark sind
diese Gräben bemannt also sitzen da die
Russen wirklich drin und wenn ja wie
viele und sind das dann gut trainierte
motivierte Einheiten oder sind das
irgendwelche Armen mobics die sofort
drauf gehen und das ist aber eine
wichtige Frage
weil es reicht nämlich nicht
irgendwelche Gräben ins Gelände zu
stellen sondern man muss natürlich diese
Gräben auch bemalen und wenn Sie jetzt
vielleicht noch mal raussuchen und sie
schauen sich die Gesamtheit dieser
Gräben an also allein der frontsektor
von saporicia bis bis dann jetzt sind
ungefähr 300 km Linie wenn Sie alle
Kurven äh hier mitzählen in den Gräben
die sie da verteidigen müssen also
allein an diesem frontsektor bräuchten
sie so wenn Sie es mit rückwärtiger
Logistik und Reserven und so weiter
aufbauen bräuchten sie 60.000 Mann und
allein diesen Abschnitt wirklich
komplett zu machen das ist aber mehr als
ein gesamter russische Truppe in diesem
Sektor steht das heißt es geht gar nicht
sie können also nicht gleichmäßig alles
bemannen und das zwingt die Russen wie
ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe zu
Schwerpunktbildung also sie müssen
irgendwo ihre ihre Truppen konzentrieren
und jetzt kommt das Problem was wenn
diese ukrainische Offensive die jetzt
gerade dort stattfindet gar nicht die
hauptoffensive ist sondern die in
Wirklichkeit ganz woanders stattfinden
und das ist das
gefährliche für die Russen die Ukrainer
können sich aussuchen wo sie vorrücken
und oder nur eine Ablenkung aber die
Russen müssen ständig entscheiden wo
konzentrieren Sie Ihr Material und Sie
müssen notfalls dieses ganze Material
auch immer wieder hin und her schieben
und deswegen kämpft die Ukraine im
Moment so wie sie wie sie es tut also
mit mit einer dezentralen Strategie mit
mehreren Angriffen gleichzeitig wo sie
eben nicht wissen ist das jetzt der
Hauptstoß oder nicht und wir wissen noch
aus der damaligen Verkauf Vision
Operation und auch aus der Brücke
Eroberung von Fresse und immer wenn die
Ukraine so penetrant auf ein bestimmtes
Gebiet hinweist dann ist das meistens
ein Zeichen dafür dass der wirklich
angekommen das stattfindet das könnte
sein dass alles was wir jetzt südlich
von welliger Norbert sehen dass das
einfach nur so eine Art Test ist wie gut
sind die Russen da aufgestellt und die
Wirklichkeit passiert der hauptschluss
ganz normal dazu haben wir auch gleich
mal eine Frage aus der Community da
fragt jemand auf Youtube wie schätzen
sie denn aktuell die Lage der russischen
Logistik ein wir haben schon gehört
Personal kann eigentlich nicht genug da
sein um alle Gräben dort zu bemalen es
gibt ja auch aus Russland immer wieder
Meldungen zu beschädigten Bahnlinien
richtig ja das war eigentlich
bemerkenswert wir hatten zu gerade zu
Anfang dieser Woche eine neue Runde von
Eisenbahn Partisanen die aber nicht im
eigentlichen Frontgebiet wo wir jetzt
gerade darüber sprechen operiert haben
sondern weiter im Süden und auch auf der
Krim und es wurde auch das Lokomotiv
Depot geschossen das dass die Russen
bisher an der Südfront nutzen und ich
denke dass das steht damit in
Zusammenhang also sprich die russische
Logistik in diesem frontsektor
auszuschalten und ebenfalls muss man
dazu zählen ähm das Hauptquartier in
Genitiv auf der Krim also genau gesagt
ähm auf der auf der Arbeit der Halbinsel
das getroffen wurde obwohl das weit
außerhalb der Front liegt aber in
Genitiv da sitzt eben das Oberkommando
der gesamten Südfront und das wurde
vermutlich durch Storm shadow
endlich getroffen und ich denke das
waren also wirklich
Vorbereitungshandlungen die auf diese
gesamte Südfront gewirkt haben und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass man die damit
eben vor allem die Verschiebung
russischer Fähigkeiten oder russischen
Materials entlang der Südfront
verhindern will und damit die Russen
zwingen des Material irgendwohin zu
stellen und dort dann auch fest zu
nageln weil sie es einfach nicht mehr
gut hin und her bewegen können und dann
würde die russische Front quasi
erstarren also sie haben dann keine
Mobilität mehr und sobald das der Fall
ist müsste sich die Ukraine dann einfach
nur noch die Lücken aussuchen und dort
dann massiv durchstoßen also soweit die
Theorie jetzt muss man natürlich aber
sehen dass dieses Gelände nicht einfach
so durchfahren werden kann sondern das
ist natürlich vollständig vermiet ist
das heißt also die nächste Phase die wir
wahrscheinlich sehen ist dass die
Ukraine größere Korridore frei machen
wird also mit mit Leidenschaft ist das
ist so eine Spezialmunition
jemand verschießt die bringt die Minen
zum Explodieren in einem gewissen
und ähm also vielleicht vier bis 800
Meter maximal und durch diesen Korridor
könnte dann ein Verband größerer
Fahrzeuge durchstoßen
da würde ich einmal wir haben nämlich
noch ein Stück eines Kollegen der noch
mal ein bisschen zusammenfasst was
eigentlich die Herausforderung diese
Offensive ist lassen Sie uns danach
nochmal auf das Gerät zu sprechen kommen
thomas gonsor hat für euch mal
zusammengefasst was gerade die
Herausforderung sind
ein Feld ein Schlachtfeld bei bachmut
mühsam kämpfen sich pro ukrainische
Soldaten durch zerfurchte Erde durch
Gänge und Gräben angelegt hat sie das
russische Militär aus der Luft sieht man
labyrinthische russische Stellungen
Unterstände fallen und anderswo
panzerhindernisse wie die sogenannten
Drachenzähne all das errichtet während
Kiew Monate lang auf Waffen wartete
sagen Experten konkret gibt's überall an
der Front russische Befestigungsanlagen
auch erdwelle und Minenfelder etwas
Gelände gewann die Ukraine zurück sagt
Kiew bei bachmut 500 Meter bei saporicia
immerhin drei bis sieben Kilometer beim
Vorrücken verlor Kiew viele Soldaten
tragisch und ein strategisches Problem
denn Militärs sagen um hier
durchzubrechen braucht die Ukraine etwa
viermal mehr Soldaten als der Gegner und
viel mehr Unterstützung aus der Luft
Militär Nachschub eine Bedingung für
größere ukrainische Erfolgsmeldungen die
anderen Zeit und Geduld
ja und Thema Militär Nachschub Thema
schwereres Gerät ich glaube darauf
wollten sie auch gerade hinaus sie haben
gesagt wir sind in Phase 2 diese
Korridore die wir da gerade sehen sind
noch sehr schmal was wäre jetzt die
dritte Phase und vor allem was für Gerät
bräuchte es für diese dritte Phase
ja ich würde sagen das Gerät ist
eigentlich schon da also die wirklich
schweren Kampfmittel z.B die britischen
Challenger auch der Großteil der Leopard
Panzer auch der Großteil der Bradley kam
Flugzeuge ist ja bisher gar nicht
eingesetzt worden also der der
Einspieler den sie gerade gezeigt haben
der würde sagen der ist relativ
pessimistisch einfach also er erwähnt
ein wichtiges Element nämlich die
fehlende lufthan Halt und ähm da würde
ich sagen das ist tatsächlich riskant
eine große Offensive zu beginnen wenn
sie nicht vollständige Lufthoheit haben
andererseits muss man auch sagen die
Effektivität der russischen Luftwaffe
ist bisher relativ begrenzt wenn wir den
gesamten Kriegsverlauf anschauen
wenn Sie fragen was was ist die nächste
Phase dann würde ich sagen sobald fest
steht wo ein Front Durchbruch möglich
ist also wo die Schwachstellen in diesem
Grabensystem sind dann werden wir von
den leichten Brigaden die wir im Moment
sehen zu den schweren Brigaden übergehen
das heißt also in den Verbänden die
jetzt operieren sind mehrere Panzer oder
Bradley m2 eher noch die Ausnahme wenn
der schwere Durchbruch kommt dann wird
das die Regel sein das heißt dann sehen
wir nicht vereinzelte oder Fahrzeuge mit
solchen Verbänden sondern werden dann
werden wir dutzende davon sehen die dann
auch im Verbund hervor brechen und das
ist wirklich auch ein Novum in der
Moderne und Kriegsgeschichte weil in
Europa hat es seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
keine größeren Operationen gegeben die
einen ein Land Krieg in dieser massiven
Größe wirklich fahren und koordinieren
also die Ukraine betritt hier wirklich
Neuland und natürlich ist da auch ein
gewisses Risiko dabei auf der anderen
Seite muss man aber auch sagen dass die
russischen Kräfte vielleicht nicht so
stark sind wie so manche Experten das
vielleicht vermuten und das sehen Sie in
einem ganz einfachen Punkt wenn Russland
noch in der Lage wäre selbst vorzurücken
oder selbst offensiven zu starten dann
würde es sich nicht im Gelände
eingegraben ja also allein die die
Tatsache dass diese ganzen Strukturen er
werden das zeigt Ihnen einfach dass auch
die russischen Kräfte natürlich
erschöpft sind und die Frage ist jetzt
nicht so sehr wer hat wie viel Systeme
oder wer hat wie viel Verluste sondern
der Krieg geht jetzt über von der
eigentlichen taktischen in die
logistische Phase das heißt den Krieg
hält derjenige durch der die bessere
Logistik hat und der quasi unbegrenzten
nachflug hat und zu dem Thema fällt mir
immer ähm soll ich sagen ein gewisser
pensionierter deutscher general ein der
hat ja mal gesagt
dass oder ich glaube mich zu erinnern
ich frage mich jetzt hat er das so
gesagt dass doch Russland angeblich die
logistische Basis hinter sich habe und
unendliche Material nachschieben können
und da habe ich mir gedacht ja so falsch
ist es eben nicht vielleicht hat er
einfach Russland verwechselt mit der
United States Army äh die macht das
nämlich im Moment und sagt okay ihr habt
jetzt gerade 15 Grad ist verloren oder
vielleicht sind sie nicht kaputt aber
man muss jetzt Abschleppen egal hier
sind die nächsten 15
aber lassen Sie mich das noch sagen das
ist nämlich genau der Punkt das ist
genau der Punkt ja also entscheidend ist
nicht wie viel Material verlieren sie
sondern wie schnell und auf welchem
Qualitätsniveau kann das ganze ersetzt
werden also die permanente
nachschubfähigkeit ja und da hat der
Herr durchaus recht gehabt also diese
logistische Komponente die wird Kriegs
entscheidend sein und nicht die
vereinzelten Gefechte oder die
frontbewegung über die die Medien halt
so gerne berichten weil das eben Bilder
erzeugt Logistik ist halt ein bisschen
langweilig und technisch aber am Ende
gewinnt die Logistik den Krieg was die
Community hier gerade noch interessiert
ist noch mal das Thema Luftunterstützung
bzw Luftwaffe und hier sagt jemand eine
offensive ohne Luftunterstützung ist
sehr gefährlich die westlichen Panzer
sind zwar feuertechnisch gut aber gegen
Panzerabwehrwaffen genauso anfällig wie
alte Panzer würden sie damit gehen dass
das hier jemand sagt eine offensive ohne
Luftunterstützung ist eigentlich
fahrlässig und was ist mit den F16
Flugzeugen würden die jetzt helfen also
ich würde ich würde teilweise mitgehen
ich müsste das etwas ausbreiten also
zunächst mal ist es stimmt dass
normalerweise also wenn man das nach
Handbuch macht dann etabliert man erst
Luftüberlegenheit und dann schickt man
die Bodensysteme los und die Luft
Überlegenheit schützt einfach die
Operation am Boden wenn sie das nicht
haben heißt es aber nicht dass es
deswegen nicht funktionieren kann
sondern dann müssen sie halt beurteilen
wie stark sind eigentlich die luftmittel
des Gegners und wenn wir jetzt die
Performance der russischen Luftwaffe
anschauen im Verlauf dieses Krieges dann
würde ich sagen
zeigt sich Russland eigentlich immer
noch als als das was ist eigentlich ist
nämlich es ist eine große Artillerie
Armee mit ziemlich schlecht
ausgebildeter in Vertrieb also die
russische Armee ist und war übrigens
schon immer also von ganzen 20
Jahrhundert eigentlich einen Land Armee
nicht so sehr eine Armee die durch ihre
luftmittel
gegrenzt hat und
wenn wir wenn wir anschauen wie stark er
die russische Luftwaffe auf die
strategische Bomberflotte bisher in den
Krieg eingegriffen dann würde ich sagen
viel weniger stark als viele übrigens
auch ich das vermutet haben
wenn die russische Luftwaffe eingreift
dann sieht das eher vereinzelte Aktionen
das heißt sie fliegen entweder kurz rein
mit dem Kampfhubschrauber und dann
gleich wieder raus oder sie fliegen eben
in den Luftraum hinein und feuern von
dort aus Mario Körper ab auf zivile
Objekte Klammer auf was natürlich ein
Kriegsverbrechen ist Klammer zu aber
solange die russische Luft aber nicht
wirklich weit überlegen ist und die Luft
kommt komplett dominiert würde ich sagen
kann man dieses Risiko kalkulieren und
jetzt kommt das Thema F16 das große
Problem der Ukraine ist dass ich die
Russen immer noch relativ ungestraft in
Großteilen des Luftraums bewegen können
also dort wo die moderne Abwehr steht
also insbesondere die Patriots in der
Umgebung von tief da können sie nicht
mehr fliegen da werden sie ziemlich
schnell abgeschossen im südlichen
frauensektor ist das anders
wenn die Ukraine jetzt aber F16 bekommt
und das ist keine Frage mehr das ob das
ist nur eine Frage wann genau wie viele
und von wem im Moment verhandeln Sie
gerade mit Australien aber so richtig
fest zugesagt hat das ja noch niemand
bis jetzt ja gut dass das will nicht
viel heißen dass ich meine wir haben uns
ja noch im Januar dieses Jahres über die
Frage unterhalten ob Panzer jetzt nicht
eine furchtbar gefährliche Waffe sind
und ob man die jetzt doch nicht
vielleicht etwas besonderer liefern
sollte ich weiß nicht wer das damals
genauso vertreten hat aber man kann
schon die Frage stellen wie schnell sich
solche Dialoge dann drehen wenn wenn die
richtigen Menschen dann die richtigen
Entscheidungen treffen ich möchte diese
Frage ja nicht beantworten aber ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass in der
Vergangenheit vieles dann doch plötzlich
ganz schnell gegen wenn man die
militärische Notwendigkeit eingesehen
hat und die militärischen Notwendigkeit
ist natürlich klar also wenn die
ukraineische Luft wäre sich Luftabwehr
sich abnutzt in diesen Krieg ähm dann
dann bringt es natürlich der Ukraine
nichts also sie braucht definitiv Ersatz
weil die authentischen Waffensysteme
langsam in diesem Krieg untergehen und
die einzige Möglichkeit sie zu ersetzen
vor allem auf einem höheren
technologien-niveau ist eben westliche
Technologie das heißt das ist eine Frage
die die eigentlich militärisch geklärt
ist das ist hauptsächlich eine
politische Frage es muss halt sich
wieder irgendein arndt von Winkelried
quasi finden der sagt ich springe hier
in die breche und und ich mache euch
eine Gasse frei und und irgendeiner wird
halt politisch hinstehen müssen und der
erste sein der sie liefert vermutlich
werden dass die Niederlande sein weil
die haben schon sehr deutliches Signale
gegeben aber es ist nicht so dass man
das jetzt noch ernsthaft diskutieren
würden
sie natürlich auch den Luftraum dann
anders dominieren und und wahrscheinlich
auf dem großen dann untersagen sich in
diesen loskommen zu bewegen wir haben
noch eine Frage
zur anderen Seite und User ist wenn
odental fragt hat man eigentlich
Erkenntnisse wie es auf der anderen
Seite der Front aussieht interessant
wäre ja auch zu erfahren wie die
Ausstattung und die nachschubversorgung
auf russische
aussehen welche Rolle können die Zivil
Milizen auf russischer Seite für die
ukrainische Offensive spielen ja also
wie gesagt dass das beste Bild dass es
sich eigentlich machen können vom
strategischen Problem Russlands ist wenn
sie auf der Karte hinaus zoomen und sich
fragen was steht eigentlich hinter der
Hauptverteidigungslinie also was steht
hinter den Gräben Antwort nichts danach
kommt nichts mehr und dann kommt die
Schwarzmeerküste und danach kommt die
Stadt meditopol mit der mit Abstand
größten partisanenaktivität die wir an
der gesamten Südfront haben man sieht
die Leute warten nur drauf dass ich da
etwas abzeichnet an der Hauptkampflinie
und das ist eigentlich der der Punkt von
dem aus Mann die russische Logistik
betrachten muss also die die Frage ist
in die die sich viele Stellen wie viel
russische Reserve steht noch in diesem
rückwärtigen Raum also ich hinter der
Hauptverteidigungslinie bis zur
schwarzen Küste und wie mobil ist die
noch also sprich wohin will die sich
bewegen
wenn die Partisanen die Straßen und die
Eisenbahnverbindungen Kappen die
Eisenbahnverbindung sind bereits
größtenteils zerstört aber noch sind die
Straßenverbindungen offen und ich
vermute mal wenn sich ein ukrainischer
Erfolg abzeichnen sollte dann werden wir
deutlich mehr partisanenaktivität sehen
die dann auch versuchen werden die
letzten Straßenverbindungen damit auch
die Mobilität der Russen zu blockieren
was Sie auf jeden Fall machen können ist
sie können Videos sich angucken von
russischen Truppenbewegungen oder vor
allem von russischen munitionsbewegungen
und schauen Sie mal wie das
transportiert wird also ob es per
Eisenbahn transportiert wird oder ob es
per Lastwagen transportierte dann muss
man auch sehen die Russen haben wenig
bis gar keine mechanisierte Logistik und
man sieht sonst Transport ist immer noch
weiteres Kind per Hand also mit
Handarbeit mit mit Muskelarbeit was die
Russen dazu zwingt viel kleinere und
dezentralere Munitionslager anzulegen
und das belastet natürlich Logistik weil
sie dann zu großflächigen massierten
Verschiebungen nicht mehr nicht mehr in
der Lage sind und so muss man muss man
die Logistik sich anschauen aber wie
gesagt viel viel Raum ist das nicht mehr
was da jetzt dazwischen steht bis zur
schwarzen Küste und das ist denke ich
die die hauptdrohung die die Ukraine
aufstellen kann also die die
Schwarzmeerküste in kurzer Zeit zu
erreichen und dann stellt sich halt für
die russischen Verbände die Frage wohin
wollen sie dann noch verschieben und
dann haben sie noch genau zwei
Möglichkeiten sie verschieben entweder
östlich auf die Creme dann haben sie
aber das Problem da können sie nur über
die arabert oder über diese eine Straße
hier ähm die auf die krimin hineinführt
also bei der Niesky unten oder sie
verschieben eben über Mario Paul in den
in den Sektor der Front wenn sie dazu
noch in der Lage sind aber diese Truppen
die kommen dann logistisch unter großen
Stress
und vielleicht abschließend noch mal
ihre Prognose wie sich diese ukrainische
gegen Offensive entwickeln wird wie
können wir uns das zeitlich vorstellen
was wird da ihrer Meinung nach in den
nächsten Monaten passieren
also man darf es sich nicht so schnell
und einfach vorstellen also es wäre es
ein Spaziergang ich denke wir werden so
die nächsten Wochen weiter das sehen was
wir jetzt auch sehen also diese
kleineren verteilten Vorstöße mit
überwiegend leichtem Material wo also
schwere Panzer noch die Ausnahme sind
solange bis irgendwo ein Punkt gefunden
wird wo man möglicherweise durchbrechen
kann und was wir auch sehr viel mehr
sehen werden sind diese Schläge weit ins
Hinterland der Front also mit mit Storm
also mit länger reichender Raketen
Artillerie um die russischen Kommando
Strukturen und die russischen
logistischen Zentrum herauszunehmen und
das wird sicher noch den Sommer über
andauern und wenn das so läuft wie ich
mir das gedacht habe und ja auch schon
häufiger prognostiziert dann könnten wir
vielleicht so im September die dritte
Phase sehen also den größeren Durchbruch
dann mit mit schweren Systemen auf
größeren
danke dass Sie meine und die Fragen der
Community so ausführlich beantwortet
haben gerne schönen Abend noch
ja und ich werfe zum Schluss noch mal
einen Blick in die Kommentare euch
treibt das Thema wie immer um und ich
denke wir werden da noch einige Male
darüber berichten hier ist noch ein
Kommentar von Eric liques auf Youtube
der sagt mir gefällt eure Sendung sehr
des Weiteren auch ein großes Kompliment
an Herrn Kolb ich teile seine
Einschätzung zu 100%. ob diese
Einschätzung sich tatsächlich so
entwickeln werden an der ukrainischen
Front wir bleiben weiterhin für euch
dran danke für eure fragen Kommentare
und bis zum nächsten Mal